the tension is to kind of make you think
about this area and about this question
in a bit differently so like let's start
with the most important thing here like
why we are even here it's especially
let's talk about our love of the play so
why do we love deep reading so we
actually spent the time inside as
opposed to in outside well there are
many reasons to love deeper ink one of
them are just all really cool
applications that kind of really inspire
us in kind of this is you know how our
world will be better once these things
are both were there that's clearly one
way one way the other way is that they
have these cool applications in these
cool videos like self-driving cars and
whatever you know essentially this all
is just you know this is the world we
should strive to live in no question
about that
and there is even more reason to love
deep learning you know and the reason is
that actually it tends to do the most
important thing in the world it is you
know optimizing the accuracy on imagenet
data no that's also a very important
task and also actually the other thing
that people really like you know deep
learning for is that somehow the way the
representations actually learns ok so we
have this kind of mythos of kind of the
way this deep neural network learns it's
essentially like at each level of the
network it kind of is learning like more
and more advanced features more and more
high level features this is something
extremely appealing and kind of very
much resonating with any hue so this
hydrogen to love deep learning however I
must admit at least for me that this is
a very difficult law ok because
essentially as much as I would like to
love deep learning for all of these
reasons each time you look a little bit
closer you realize that things are not
exactly right
ok so for instance in terms of
application you know as much as you know
Tesla's are cool when they actually work
they sometimes don't and they sometimes
don't in a very very disturbing way so
here is just a test Lockhart that is
trying to run into divider and the
driver has to take over to avoid
collision and even on imagenet you know
you have pictures like that so the
correct classification here is that this
is an insect if you didn't know but for
some reason the model insists this is a
dog ok and it's not clear to me why
would it make such a message
able to distinguish between a very
precise breeds of the dog and for some
reason this is also a dog dude okay and
also you know even if the substations
actually turned out to be quite nice
they kind of are not exactly wood they
seem so in particular it's it's very
much not hard to have kind of pictures
that essentially are mapped to this same
essentially the same representation but
of course look completely different okay
so whatever is the internal
representation of this models use it's
not exactly aligned with how we humans
would like to think about it okay so
these are the kind of the the problems
and of course the question is what's
going on and I'm hope that in this talk
I will convince you that many of these
problems stemmed from the one reason or
one a phenomena namely the phenomena of
abuse alia robustness and as I said the
existence of a de Cerio perturbation
okay so here of course we have the right
example of a vessel example I'm still
offended that in the other example use
the Panda so we will talk about that
after the talk of course why this is the
best example because you have we can say
the usual joke about this that you know
this is how you know machine learning
can learn the pigs to fly you know
essentially like I know sure to the joke
for the other for the other example but
yet but this is kind of as funny as it
is you know kind of we already know and
that's thanks to you know to because
great talk we know that there is kind of
something he knows very serious benedi
we need right in particular we know that
somehow what it really tells us is that
the way our model generalize is maybe
not the way we would like them to
generalize and in particular if you
wanted to fix this kind of glitches
which can actually give rise to real
problems you might want to think about
something that we call adversely robot
realization essentially in which kind of
you would like to have a classifier that
still has good prediction even if you
look worst-case over all the possible
perturbations that you are you would
like this classifier to be robust
okay so again similarly to Zico I don't
want to get into what this exact class
of perturbations are it should be I
might comment on this towards the end
but the point is that there are some
natural
chances you would like that any
reasonable model should have and kind of
and somehow you realize that no unless
you ask for it you actually don't have
it
so this is the way to actually
explicitly ask okay and you know so this
is this we realizes to be a goal it took
you know a little bit to a while to
actually start getting towards this goal
but you know as a ready it was clear
from zero stock we are actually
succeeding somewhat in getting there so
this is all great and in particular you
know like so we are able to start like
getting some ones that are robust in at
least some weak sense but this this weak
sense was something that seemed to be
hard to achieve you know that's a year
ago so we're making fast progress and
also we are starting to learn about what
does change about ml as we go from kind
of the standardized ending of a malware
we just don't worry about this adversely
perturbations to an ml that actually is
guaranteed or is supposed to be
guaranteed to be robust to them so the
things that we discover is first of all
that the training of this kind of models
becomes harder and also like sometimes
this is actually not necessarily true
for for Zico's like you know smooth
randomized smoothing approach but kind
of you definitely have to work harder to
train this model so if you want to use
you know robust training it's a more
expensive procedure you need larger
models and essentially things become
difficult there are other things that we
actually realizes also that these models
you know even though they kind of become
robust they also seem to sometimes
necessarily sacrifice something so
essentially they sometimes need to
actually you know compromise standard
accuracy you have to necessarily pay
this price and also we learn that kind
of sometimes to actually even be able to
get a robust classifier you actually
might need more data than what you need
for standard like to just get a
standardization there is also this kind
of you know other information theoretic
eliminations so we are learning and
discovering this this all these things
and this is cool but somehow you know as
happy as I am about this progress there
was there wasn't actually still is a
little bit of this content that I had
essentially we start to understand how
and what so socially how to get
robustness and what kind of being robust
means
and somehow I still could not convince
myself that I know why okay
in particular essentially the one the
one mystery that I had was you know why
adversary traditions exist in the first
place maybe this is not that surprising
what is more surprising is why they are
so widespread okay this is this is what
I really found surprising also even
bigger mystery to me was why this
perturbation sent to transfer so this is
phenomena that I might choose a kind of
a perturbation that fools one model and
then I use exactly the same perturbation
to fool another model to attack another
model and it usually works
and this didn't make sense to me that
kind of like why this is the case I
understand that a given model might be
fooled by like you know just you know
just leveraging some of the bleachers of
it but why the same kind of trick works
for very different models with different
architecture trained even on the
independent sampling of the data why is
it happening the other thing is like why
robust training works and again there
are some intuitions of coming from
optimization but this intuition have
some leap of faith and kind of it still
is unnerving me a bit why kind of know
what is really happening there and it is
even like somewhere for randomized
smoothing even though there was a very
nice intuition that is equal presented
like somehow I think that this does
maybe we know why it works but a kind of
I would like to show that there is a
different way of looking at the question
and let's just start with trying to
answer the first one okay so why are our
models brittle and of course this is a
question that was asked over and over
and different explanations have been
offered you know some of them said this
is a you know this is the reason is here
that we are working with high
dimensional models and in high
dimensional you know domain others say
this is jasja in a kind of some kind of
statistical sub tuitions showing up
another one say that this is kind of a
of course you know this is just we are
optimizing for expected performance and
here we measure worst-case performance
so what would you expect there are also
people who claim that this is some kind
of punishment that we get for using
resinates that's also a valid a valid
theory but somehow what all of these
explanations have in common that they're
really
you adversary examples as something an
aberration like something that if we did
our training right or if we do our
training cried they will go away okay so
even this very interesting work that
Peter mentioned that essentially they
might be an artifact of ours being over
parametrizing and interpreting the data
in some ways you could imagine that if
you don't interpolate the data and you
kind of generalize in a different way
you know then adverse other examples
might go away okay this could be
considerable in it so okay
so you know so let's let's think about
it but like before we try to answer this
question let's actually kind of try to
think about what it is about other cell
perturbations that seems to unnerve I'm
nervous okay so why we don't like them
well we don't like them because they
lead to situations like here where we
have a beautiful picture of a dog then
we add to it some meaningless noise that
of a very small magnitude and suddenly
we are getting this know essentially the
same beautiful dog but for some reason
the model insisted that's a cat that's
definitely very very annoying and you
know like that way we kind of work hard
to avoid these kind of things but kind
of the thing to realize is that this is
annoying at least so far only because
this is kind of a human perspective
especially we as a human's we know what
the dog is supposed to be and we know
that this is a meaningless lot noise and
this should be dog as well because you
know that's the we as humans we have
these priors and we know that this is
how what works so you know from our
perspective when we kind of solved one
of the most important problems in the
world of like distinguishing cats and
dogs essentially well we know how to we
know how you should solve this task
right like you should look at this kind
of different features now to ears
and based on that you will be able to
tell is it a dog or is the cat and this
is this have to really be things that
matter for this classification task
however even though this is a very
natural human perspective you know if
you try to zoom out and think about ml
perspective you might start to wonder
right first of all from the point of
view of the you know of this poor neural
network you know for it this image is
meaningless it just a collection of
pixels is just a vector of values
it has no idea what a dog means tweet
dog is just a label no it doesn't have
any intrinsic meaning in it and there is
only one thing that this poor network is
trained to do is to maximize its
accuracy on the test so essentially like
the better way to think about it when
you think about from a machine learning
perspective is not to think about
distinguishing between dog and cats but
imagine that you as a human would be
given the task of you know there are two
classes tap and talk we have no meaning
to you and you get this kind of
collections of pixels and your job is to
distinguish between them okay and then
you stare maybe enough into them and you
write oh there is a pattern you know
that they maybe if this kind of segment
appears it this is one class if this
segment of fusion is the other class but
this district should be a really better
way of you trying to align you know what
it really means to a machine learning
model to try to solve this problem
okay and now if you look at the example
so again so to us here is this kind of
the unknowing think about you know about
this you know this is how we look at
recent examples in are annoyed by this
but from the point of view of the
machine learning classifier you know
kind of the picture might be like this
you know essentially actor yeah we have
a instance of the class top then you you
mess up some of the rectangles and then
you have an example of you know okay an
example of a of a class talk and for
some reason this is supposed to be
annoying okay you're like I'm pretty
sure that you are much less annoyed by
this part but by this part and you know
in particular one thing that you should
question immediately now is saying even
if you look at this you know at this at
this perturbation alone is this
perturbation really meaningless you know
essentially now everything is
meaningless to you why do you think that
this perturbation is meaningless as well
so let's think about it so this is the
question so our adversarial perturbation
just some kind of meaningless artifact
that kind of finds some nukes in the
model and kind of try to fool it and you
know here's the simple experiment so
what I will do is I will take a standard
you know cat versus dog training set and
what I will do is I will look at every
single example in this training set and
I will find it a very perturbation for
like may take some good model and I take
a decided exam
so essentially I attack each of the I
know the image to make it to be like to
convince the model that it is this is an
input from an opposite class so every
dog is a cut and every cut is a dog okay
so that's what I do and now I
essentially what I do is I attacking
each of these inputs I actually create a
new training set in which I take this
this kind of perturbed version of the
image and actually I put the new label
to be whatever the you know adversary
perturbation suggested it is okay so
this way I have a you know I have a new
sorry I have a new training set which is
you know essentially this dismiss
labeled like adversely perturb version
of the original training set and what I
do is I train I classify a fresh
classifier on this new test set on the
training set but then I will do
something weird
I actually test it on the original test
set okay so essentially what we are
doing here we are training classifier on
on a data set that is completely
mislabeled like there is essentially not
a single like human recognizable dog
that is labeled as dog and not a single
human credit card that is a cat still
for some magical reasons we want to test
it on a bandit to learn the concept of a
cat and so what do you think will happen
you find like whatever like we just do
the simplest thing guess this is an
honor above others who just take like a
you find the direction of the gradient
that will kind of in both directions you
have to move the image to change the
class in most efficiently and
essentially that's what you do like you
just put a little bit you don't have to
go far
like whatever it took to just fill them
all it's another Bosphorus it's very
easy to so what will happen you will do
it and essentially what you will you
will actually get a non-trivial accuracy
on the original task actually you will
get something like seven Nikon C far
cats versus dog you get 78 percent okay
so think about what's happening here
just like me it's not only that you know
it's not even that we have a noisy data
so you just handed data said that
claimed that every like there is a like
to a human if you gave if a human ever
saw a dog or a cat you will show this
the data set they will be convinced that
dogs are true are cuts and cuts are dogs
so you give such a you know such a you
know such such a training set to a
pacifier and somehow magically it
figures out that this should be the
opposite okay so what's going on here
well kind of the only explanation that
we could come up with and maybe so maybe
there is something in our mental
pictures we got wrong
essentially that when we kind of thought
like we paid a lot of attention to how
the prediction of the model changes when
you try to perturb it but we did not
really pay too much attention to what
the perturbations are themselves and
actually maybe the perturbations are not
some kind of random you know weird
aberrations maybe they actually are
meanings and in particular maybe they
don't correspond to just exactly just
like doing some mindless manipulation of
the model
maybe they they correspond to changing
some important features
we need to imitate the original network
yes that would work that would work if
the network I use the classifier on
would be the same architecture we use a
completely different architecture it
still works but that would be yet that
would be one thing that's what something
we also thought at first that
essentially you are doing like model
distillation where you kind of you know
it's kind of you encode the weight of
the model in the way things are labeled
but yet we just used to tell you
different architecture and so on and it
still works equally okay but that's a
good that's a good question I mean this
we we we ruled out okay so there's like
the kind of the concept the way we
conceptualize is just the following and
somehow the way maybe we should think
about you know how classification
happens is that there is kind of two
kinds of features in our data set okay
one of them are the kind of the what we
called robust features so essentially
there are you know features that you
know that correlate well with the label
and are robust under even if you try to
perturb the image value okay so this is
in particular things like Earth's and
snow if you just like add a bit of alto
nose they would still be ears and snot
and they were still correlate well with
the image and that's kind of that's how
we thought about things that's how we
think about you know about learning as
humans however what was interesting is
that we actually discovered that there
is a you know and there are also this
kind of non Rob there are patterns that
correspond to non robust features so
features actually are genuinely
predictive of what is the right label
they actually do than our eyes but they
are extremely brittle to perturbations
essentially what happens is that when no
the only thing that the model wants it
just wants to do as well as possible on
the test set so any feature that is
created well with the label is a good
feature to use and it turns out that
this non robust features are actually
really great they actually called it
very well with the hood the label like
we have seen it actually will model head
like the robust features were staring at
one thing and non robust which was
within the other things the model
actually trusts not robust features more
and essentially that's why because these
metrics are so good
our models tend to pick on them and
that's how to expose themselves to be
vulnerable to adversary perturbations
okay question so robust features for a
stock would be labeled as cats so what
happens is essentially I will I will I
will go through this example again and
then we can answer your question but
that's a great question
so yeah so let's just take a look take a
look at what actually happened with this
kind of robust and robust features in
mind so we had our training set in which
kind of both robots which was an and
robust features were aligned well with
the correct label now when we created
the new training set what we did is
somehow now the robust features are
since you think a different thing they
still claim this is a dog even though
them the new label is cut while the only
new neural bass features are actually
you know consistent with the new label
okay so essentially like the older
batteries are misleading and number of
oxygens are actually the one helpful and
in some ways now there is some kind of
confusion that the model has right but
essentially this confusion since it kind
of trains its realize okay these
features are like in some ways antique
alright so so what what is happening is
that kind of the non robust features
they have better correlation with the
red label so it chooses to align more on
them and yes these things are confusing
and maybe it ignores them maybe it kind
of realize there are anti-correlated or
something like this happens but somehow
they find that non-robot features alone
already good enough to correlate with
the red label kind of allows it to to
get the bulk of the prediction by the
way remember that the prediction
accuracy we got it 78 percent is of
course impressive that you can get
anything better than 50 percent but it's
not what you would get if you actually
trained on this but it could easily the
robust feature of that dog could have
been airplane or a penguin how does it
know here we just talked about the
binary classification so this is just
there are just dogs and cats yeah yeah
if you do it on Fulton like the similar
phenomena of things but yes but then the
like yeah
you see the 78% drop it says it also we
did not do that like we tested different
classifications as but who did not do
this kind of well we expected to again
and the classification has we did test
ever I own all had the similar
conclusion but we did not look it into
defined range think exactly how if you
subset adversarial examples in early no
transfer well as you're creating said
did this we did not do that but there
are some experiment that had not been
done by me it's something it's not
published yet that seems to suggest that
so so there's a very I will get back to
transferability in a moment and that's
it but yes like our hypothesis it's not
confirmed like well there are some again
not our experiments that kind of seem to
confirm it is that yes they transferable
I examples are the really the ones that
correspond to features there is also a
part of the dissenters just some
aberrations and they don't transfer well
it is possible to this is pretty tuna
Karim
did this experiment and you can actually
construct at the hair example they do
not transfer and when you do do it and
when you do this experiments with this
don't transfer your examples like this
doesn't work especially a Casper ability
seems to be intimately tied with being
the kind of meaningful okay
okay so robust features means that you
are actually like okay so we are so this
is actually a good discussion to have
after offline is essentially this are
the function of the function of the data
set that the model picks up on that are
corrected with the right label but you
can flip them by perturbing the input
let's take it offline I think this is a
good discussion but yeah like we spend a
lot of time talking about this because
here we are I will get to the very way
we don't know how this non-euro basket
just look we know they exist we have no
idea how they actually look like and
yeah and so this is essentially
defeating here so essentially yeah like
that's the that's why this experiment we
did more experience than that yeah we
are kind of you know we can talk offline
about more experiments yeah yeah no but
like we don't like because you know hey
when you make such a thesis you organize
that it's wrong and exactly like so
that's why we tested you know we did
more experiment than what is it like or
does it experiment and we are done but
there is more I'm still welcome everyone
to try to disprove it because I would
yeah
there's a different explanation I by the
neurons work at themselves robust yes so
by definition they are like this is the
our definition but it's not like you
would like to understand something more
about them it's like this is some kind
of configuration of Peaks like clearly
yeah by definition that's what they are
but you would like to have more kind of
more concrete definition for there again
we can talk about this more so I guess
the point here is that I think they both
are here is that there is kind of just
difference between the human and animal
model spires that kind of we have this
human perspective of how we should learn
and so we had heard that this is the
only
of learning but it turns out that you
know there are like different ways of
actually doing well on sanitization and
maybe that's what our fathers actually
are doing this like there is there's no
reason a priori for us to expect the
model to prefer this way of learning if
this way of learning actually might lead
to better okay so in particular this
awesome is that every second our human
phenomenon and also if you want to have
interpretable models essentially well
you have to think about it at the
training time because if you're if you
just train a model in a standard way and
then you want to explain it to a human
what is dying well then if the model is
using mineral bath features we don't
know as humans what do these features
are and how to make sense of them so you
either have to ignore that part of the
decision process or yeah or you are not
able to find a human human
understandable explanation why model
works and so if you really wanted to do
kind of doing of the more human-like
model you have to at the training time
kind of try to force the model to learn
the way the humans learn as opposed to
the model that know the way that leads
to the best generation performance okay
so this is kind of the hypothesis so
what now
so it definitely at least to me gives a
new perspective on this other busnes and
also provides insights into many other
questions as I mentioned okay so in
particular one cool color of this is
that kind of there is a new capability
you can do so see what you can do is you
can take a you know a data set then you
can essentially create you can use the
robots model to create its robusta fide
version so this is like a different
version of the object of the data set
such that essentially once you have this
training set you can just train the
model in a standard way and it actually
will not only get an AK now will learn
the concept in the standard way but also
it will be robot like it will do robot
specification so kind of the idea here
is that what you do is essentially
distill from the model like the only the
only features that you transfer to this
model are the robust models they are the
robust features kind of you this way you
cleanse the data set from non robust
perturbations and then the model one is
trans to learns it has to only write on
robust features and this actually leads
to robust custody
okay so this is about the features and
in particular you know there is a bunch
of papers that claim that okay you know
the reason why we have adversity are
vulnerabilities because here we train
with Bart norm and that's why this or we
train with Sgt and that's why it is and
essentially as long as you know your
claim is that this alone is the reason
why we are very robust this dataset is a
counterexample place because this
dataset you can train with bart norm
which over parameterize ation with
whatever you want you still we get
robustness
so essentially like so if you just want
to explain by these techniques alone why
things you know why things are
vulnerable it will not it worse it's
worse there are significant drops so so
this is just proof of concept this is
not the way the way to do it so how is
this robust ascent generated essentially
yes so that's how you get robust model
but now once you have a robust matter
how you get this essentially what you do
is you can you ask me in a moment but
there will be a better moment for this
to explain but this is a very good
question that's you know kind of how you
get there so the other the other thing
that is important is the transfer
ability so finally now transcribe it it
makes sense to me because if at the
cellular perturbation correspond to
altering non robust features into the
data and well this is a property of the
data set not on the model that you learn
so essentially you know if non robust
features are useful for the data set
models many models will find them useful
so the side perturbations that just flip
this new nervous features will all kind
of work across all of these models so
finally like this makes sense to me that
this kind of explains why you know why
transferability is happening and as I
said you know a Pritam actually train
found the non transfer greater examples
and then none of this effect that I said
they come across
so dude do you think then that these
features like human should actually
learn in their meaningful things like
actual like high-frequency correlations
or is it like a small small dataset
artifacts still or something I don't
know that's not there I think the
interesting question and the question is
okay I will get back to this question
but I don't know even say tasks for a
different I did not try that what we did
try it does happen if you start sample
the same the same date I said sub sub
like you get two different training
examples by subsampling the same data
said it still transfer but across
training this is a good question we are
supposed to do it at some point but here
we didn't so we didn't take it I
honestly I would expect if this they
guessed are similar then probably did
like essentially like a well we will get
to that that's if that's a question
that's a very good question
okay so indeed then just be the
experiment and indeed that the things
that transfer the most are exactly the
things that essentially like that there
is a clear clear seems to be clear
connection between how robust the model
you know how about the model is in how
well things transfer confirming this
hypothesis and also like if you look at
what robust training like one or like
it's another perspective of why robust
training is useful essentially as you
remember like what you do in robust
training you are kind of trying to do
like robust erm when you're essentially
like always look at the worst-case
perturbation of the thing that you want
to classify and somehow now what really
happens is that this procedure what it
does it always makes sure that you can't
depend on any patterns that can be
changed by perturbations in Delta so see
what you are doing you are making the
non robust features with respect to the
perturbation set to be useless to the
moment it was you always kind of pannier
the model if it tries to rely on them
because you click an can flip this you
know frivolous you know these features
and have the model that did it strong
okay so in some ways you are really make
the making them explicitly any other but
features you make them useless by
breaking the correlation with the
correct layer
okay and it's similar with the like
randomized randomized nothing
essentially like the intuition here is
that kind of you're just adding noise to
the to the input and this noise
overwhelms any of the signal that this
you know these features that are
sensitive perturbations actually convey
so you guys are over writing it and
that's why the model cannot learn from
it and then it just focuses on learning
for robust features and that's why you
and also finally like as I told you
there are some of these effects of kind
of lack of what we know how robots would
behave so in particular you know I
remember like if robust models can only
use robust features even though there
are and robust features that are helpful
for generalization then what happens
that you need actually more data to get
given accuracy because essentially you
are constraining the way the model can
extract patterns from the from the from
the data and also you might be getting a
lower standard accuracy because again if
you have if you give the same a move of
data to two models and one of them is
constraining weight we can extract the
patterns another one isn't clearly there
will be some there will be something
good something worse and of course the
question is you know kind of is you know
even clearly even if none are bad
features give you better accuracy
standard accuracy does it mean is doing
the right thing like in some way this is
exactly the question that you're coming
from and like it seems like should we
depend on there are robust features or
not are they actually things we want to
do are there some interesting insights
that actually makes sense and if we were
able to figure them out you would use
them or are they some completely
meaningless patterns that we should
avoid depending on so if I first like
think about if you learn cats versus
dogs from pictures on the internet one
correlation that you will probably find
is that like cats are photographed in
inside more and dogs are correct our
photographed outside more clearly this
is a useful pattern that will help you
do better but this is not the pattern
you actually would like to use like we
as humans discarded because we want to
learn the concepts of a dog or a cat so
in some ways now yes there might be like
the current deep learning would
outperform humans on this data set like
imagenet but maybe they do it by
cheating and maybe that's actually does
not mean that they actually are getting
human-like performance what would you
say about your distribution under the
architecture itself I mean what I'm
beginning is the you know the later
layers more effect so you can perturb
the early layers with noise I knew have
more practices again like I have like
five minutes ten minutes later left
something like this so I want to flick
I'm happy to go to back to this
girlfriend it's like we don't have a
good answer there but there would be
something I will show that might kind of
make the discussion after the door I
don't have good answers yes yet but just
I would there's something that will be
wrong to say and by the way you know
there is actually something we just
played the video is trying to get some a
bit like simple theoretical model to
kind of try to understand what's
happening it's like the simplest and a
very tall model you can imagine is
imagine you have just two gaussians and
essentially what you would like to do
you know so I imagine that you excrete
infinite sample regime so you know what
the distributions are and the only
question you would like to do is you
would like to do classification based on
max likelihood estimate okay so what you
would like to do well normally what you
would like to do you would like to you
know you'd like to find you know the max
likelihood parameters of kind of the
distribution you're observing and of
course if you have you know infinite
exactly recover the original means and
and covariances and then the way you
classify essentially what you say is
what we should give me an input X I just
find you know kind of the label that
makes this input X to be the most likely
right and that's how I classify and this
corresponds to essentially like this is
the closed form expression you get and
you get like boundary Casa vation
boundary like this so is it like
standard you know standard machine
learning nothing happening here but now
the question is what if I wanted to do
this classification but in a way that is
l2 robust okay so what do I mean by this
so now when you talk about
l2 robust when you talk about max
likelihood parameters you would like to
estimate like the robust Knox likelihood
expert
parameters so what you would like to say
saying that well if I have a point
somewhere here its likelihood actually
the worst case over the whole l2 ball
like epsilon radius l2 ball around this
point and kind of the meaning like they
like essentially this could be the
minimum of that will be your there will
be your kind of actual likelihood so
this is like a robust likelihood
estimation and then once you have this
robust like parameters of the
corresponding distribution then of
course the classification still works to
say okay but the obvious question now is
like what should actually be this no
they mean and covariance estimates if
you want to be robust and somehow the
intuition here is that the problem is
that kind of it's a misalignment of
geometries like this Gaussian that
cannot be they're much more sensitive in
this direction than they are in this
direction while this nice doesn't care
so in particular the adversary might
move your sample by relatively not much
in l2 distance but this may be a huge
distance in your covariance like in your
mother happy distance corresponding to
discussions so somehow this way you can
have a small perturbation of the you
know small perturbation of the input
that have big impact on this likelihood
so actually like when you do the
computation you think what is the best
robust estimate you end up with like
actually mean is still the same means do
not matter and do not matter but the
covariance matrices change we are doing
we have to start blending the actual
covariance matrices the identity matrix
which is that cannot the covariance
matrix of the geometry of the adversary
okay and here is like it so you start
like this this is what you get the best
classification boundary for you know for
know where there is no perturbations but
as you increase the perturbations you
kind of are blowing up this direction
essentially like you are fooling
yourself that this gas has put
differently than they are because you
want this max likelihood estimates to be
more robust and of moving along this
restoration so so there are some
observations to make so in some ways
again this is a twin model you should
not take it out of proportion but just
something is do to make is that actually
you know you if you just want to get
best classification you really want to
take advantage of this kind of non
robust direction like you really want to
understand that this Gaussian is kind of
looks like that but as you want to know
kind of be robust you kind of are
blowing up this direction but this of
course comes at the price of reducing
your standard occurs the other
interesting phenomena is that kind of if
you think about gradient direction if
you think about oh I am I am here at the
end the kind of let's say the center of
this you know of this caption and I
would like make this I would like to
find the closest point that kind of
belongs to a different class and I would
just look at the gradient results and
she's like it you just go perpendicular
to the decision boundary this will just
you know take you somewhere there it's
somehow will be a different direction
that kind of if you wanted to actually
go towards the center of the other
dissolution should be the natural kind
of counterpart of your point but as you
become more robust you actually this two
directions align and again this is a toy
model but kind of it illustrate
something that actually happens for you
know standard models as well okay so
essentially so this is kind of about
robustness and now the cool thing I
wanted to show it specially like for the
question you ask is saying okay so now
we know that maybe this non robust
features are something you should not be
using so the question is so how about we
use robust training to prevent our
models from using moving averages
how did this model look like well it
turns out to be pretty interesting so
usually what you happen is an again and
in the in the cleaned in the light of
what we just were talking about the
should not be less surprising once you
insist on using robust models this one
is tend to be much more aligned with
human perception than the standard
models so for instance you know over
here like there one of the popular way
of trying to understand why model made
the prediction is that sort of very
simple beam you will talk about much
more interesting ways of doing it is
kind of to use just as the gradient a
cadet the saliency Maps which is a sense
like look for each pixel and you look at
its kind of sensitivity of the
prediction to changing this pixel and if
you do it to a standard model you will
get things like that which you know are
not maybe very convincing
however if you do the same thing to a
robust model you get things like that
which kind of are much more aligned if
you ask human to annotate what was
important this probably would be much
more aligned than this here are things
that are outside of the kind of the dog
that seemed to be relevant and maybe
they didn't honorable party patterns can
show Inka but there are something in the
about the background that kind of
correlates well with the dog and kind of
you can view robustness kind of as a
prior that kind of insist on you know
kind of making the classification of the
model use only meaningful meaningful
aspects and going back to representation
so now you can again look at the deficit
ation like essentially at the
second-to-last layer and now you're
before I told you that kind of you can
it's very easy to find two images two
completely different but seem to be the
same at this level they seem to be
collage with the opposition this layer
this no longer is seems to be the case
for the robots models for robots models
like the only way we can match you know
two representations of two images if I
we start from two different noisy images
is that getting something that is very
similar how do you reconcile that with
the fact that there's just input images
are 256 or over by 256 by 3 and
representation you're looking at is like
1000 dimensional or four thousand
dimensional whatever it is really going
to mean many many many inputs they map
on to the same output is it that they're
truly this is actually the property of
gradient descent would you because
you're finding from the random
initializations by HDD right it's so so
I I want to take it offline because we
fought about it and we just there's
something weird happening by the way how
the mapping of the images like into this
kind of into this space happen secession
there are like even though in principle
this is high dimensional like more high
dimensional in reality actually it's it
seems to be much lower dimensional so
and then like essentially like it seems
to work the way you do like like I just
described it kind of for meaningful
images the only closeby things are also
meaningful images are very close to that
image
there are some part of complete noise
that things kind of behave differently
but also what is interesting is that
there are directions in which a kind of
there is many vectors over here that if
you try to find an input that maps into
them you can't guess we don't know how
to do it so so there seems to be
something interesting happening there
and remember that you know here there
are like different like you know like
reduction in dimensions happening and so
on and something so so did you say this
is a complicated you see the two you're
gonna get something and that really good
and good layer yes so let's stop it
since I only have two minutes a I'm
happy to take like again I don't have it
for answer but it seems to so far work
exactly as you'd expect and I'm happy to
discuss this more so what I want to say
is that the several conditions are
really cool because they allow you like
with this to do this like feature many
places and visualizations that again we
have seen before this is one of the cool
things but now you can do it in a
extremely simple way you just like do
the most obvious things you could
imagine doing and it just works and
there is no priors needed normalization
no post-processing and essentially you
are really faithful to the model itself
and essentially so yeah you can do
things like interpolations so you can
just take you know two images and find a
way to interpolate between them in a
kind of way that is kind of you know
perception consistent for humans like
it's actually if you are morphing
one image into other so again we knew
how to do it before but here you can do
it for any two inputs even if they are
out of the data set like normally you
have to extract it from the kind of
embedding of the of the images that
there are this kind of interesting crowd
here you just like take two things you
find the line in the in between them in
their presentation space and you just
match everything on this path and that's
how you are getting this getting this
interpolations you can do direct feature
very visualization you can just see for
every neuron kind of you know what that
kind of you know essentially like in
like if I push more this you know this
this more and more
what kind of images I get so essentially
right this is some frog eNOS neuron this
is some
neuron and so on and this is kind of
like it again it's as easy as it as it
sounds you can also see like do the
other way you can just ask here's a
neuron you know what are the images that
correlate best with it and what are the
images the worst Megan you are getting
exactly what you would expect and you
know and similar thing you can also do
like no future manipulation so you can
just take an image you find a neuron
that corresponds to stripes you increase
this new and a bit and you are getting a
tiger and again all of this we could do
it before there was cycle gun but now
it's extremely simple and actually much
more robust than what you know how it
works before you can also do like you
know future levers STV analysis so
remember this image was confusing it
essentially the model got wrong now you
can actually understand why it got to
why it got it wrong so you can try to
enhance the top two features that kind
of are possible for the prediction when
you enhance them you realize that
actually this part over here it actually
looks quite a bit as a dog as a dog face
and as you know image that has many dogs
and it likes to hallucinate dogs
everywhere and that's what happened here
that's why this happened and you know
you can do much more things you can do
actually image generation like in a very
simple way and interestingly like you
know in contrast to guns this actually
the more data you have the easier it is
to make it work so this is again no
optimization Notary picking this is what
you get by extremely simplistic methods
you can do super resolution you can do
in painting you can even do cool things
like this where you kind of can take
kind of look and do the kind of day I
assisted painting you just catch
something and then you ask the you know
the model to make it more realistic you
can also like take an input and make it
more into the input of other class so
she can morph you know like yet there
was a pineapple into a tiger and
especially you can play quite a bit this
is actually there is a demo that you can
take a look at and you can play with it
quite a bit and enjoy enjoy the ride
so let me just finish and essentially so
I guess the cheese's here is that the
cell examples arise from non robust
features in the data that actually exist
again this which not only exists they
actually do seem to help a lot
internalization
today essentially robust training and
another mess moving prevents our models
from using them and that's kind of how
the robustness arises and again and it
also explains a lot of aspects of robot
success for ability and so on it also
like enables this new capability of row
pacification that you can just robust
defy the data set as opposed to always
train them all that is robust and again
it's also makes this stronger message
that you interpret ability needs to be
addressed at the training time this is
something you have to think from the
beginning and kind of the robots models
like if you do that then the robots
models are more human aligned and again
there is a lot of cool stuff you can do
and then just the one the last point I
wanted to make is that as much as I care
about robustness myself I really it
would be a to me a failure if you've
really viewed everything I said only to
read through the lens of like robustness
and security because it's a vessel
robustness by now it's not only about
like it robots to an adversary it's to
me really about understanding how our
models learn okay so in particular what
is the right notional translation so we
already move to the question of robot
realization because it's clearly like
more aligned with what we expect and
standard you know iid generalization
itself and in particular there's this
question that you know is really just
maximizing the accuracy really the right
goal now now maybe like it's clearly a
more nuanced question now and we really
have to confirm this question as opposed
to just know having one number and
saying the better number you get the
better job you did the other questions
this is also fee that been mentioned and
I also think is important is the
distribution shift so kind of the real
problem seems to not be to how to get
the iid generalization it seems to be
how to get models that are robust to
distribution shift one thing that I
guess Ben is not here I think I didn't
agree with van is that actually like
even though he shows these examples of
failures with distribution shift I kind
of I think before you can say that there
is a failure of the of adjustment to the
submission shift you have to find some
way to measure what distribution shift
is right because clearly when the
submission shift is large you know then
it's not surprising that the model
performs badly like if you suddenly we
know reliable every cut to a dog you
should not blame the model that it's
does the wrong thing and in some ways
again now this is something that depends
on representation so maybe even though
this like image net
one or one even though to humans it
seemed that there should be only minimal
data shift maybe it is me man deter
shift to humans but from the point in
robust features maybe it's completely
different so we really don't understand
that and that's something so before we
talk about robots description shift you
should find a way of measuring it and
find a way of how representations play
your order and the other questions
exactly like how well how do we value
human alignment interpretability because
three there is a price like you get
worst accuracy performance so the
question is how much you value it how
important is for different applications
and somehow I've you a better arrow
buttons as kind of just the framework
for making our models better and what
better means is kind of you think of
adversary as a way to encapsulate human
critics and should you say okay I don't
like this kind of features to be used
and that's how I interpret an adversary
that penalizes the model for using them
and this is the way to refine the way we
you know we only train our models so
that's all I have to say we have some
blog post on our on our on our kind of
website and that kind of go in more
depth there like there are some cool
demos there so
way over time so yeah I would be outside
yeah